en el vídeo anterior aprendimos sobre
núcleo filos y electro filos y en este
vídeo veremos algunos mecanismos simples
de química orgánica y aprenderemos a
identificar electro filos y núcleo filos
y también veremos cómo mostrar los
movimientos de electrones en un
mecanismo si se acuerdan de química
general los mecanismos muestran los
pasos por los que ocurre una reacción
por ejemplo para esta reacción
analicemos el alumno de alquilo o
también llamado halogenuro de alquilo
que tenemos del lado izquierdo
sabemos que el cloro es más electro
negativo que este carbono
entonces el cloro retira densidad
electrónica del carbono con lo que el
carbono se vuelve parcialmente positivo
por el vídeo anterior sabemos que como
este carbono tiene una carga parcial
positiva este es el centro electro
físico de nuestro compuesto y si
analizamos el ión hidróxido que lo
podemos obtener por ejemplo del
hidróxido de sodio sabemos que éste
cargado negativamente es la parte núcleo
física así que el hidróxido actúa como
un núcleo filo y este carbono en nuestro
haluro de alquilo actúa como un electro
filo y como las cargas opuestas se
atraen el oxígeno cargado negativamente
es atraído al carbón o parcialmente
positivo del alumno de alquilo y así
podemos ver que el núcleo filo ataca al
electro filo entonces podemos dibujar
una flecha curva para mostrar el
movimiento de esos dos electrones hasta
este carbono y al mismo tiempo estos dos
electrones se van junto con el cloro
entonces el cloro ya tenía tres pares de
electrones libres a su alrededor vamos a
dibujarlos
y le vamos a agregar un par de
electrones libres extra que voy a
resaltar de color rosa estos electrones
se van con el cloro y podemos decir que
corresponden a este par eso le da al
cloro una carga 1 negativa este es el
avión de cloro y se le conoce como
nuestro grupo saliente entonces vamos a
formar un enlace entre el oxígeno y este
carbono que tiene una carga parcial
positiva vamos a decir que este par de
electrones libres en el oxígeno forman
un enlace entre el oxígeno y ese carbono
y en nuestro producto en el alcohol esos
2 electrones corresponden a estos
electrones que forman este enlace y ese
es un mecanismo de química orgánica muy
sencillo solamente tenemos un paso el
núcleo fy lo atacó y el grupo saliente
se fue todo eso ocurrió en el mismo paso
y el objetivo no es que entendamos cada
una de las cosas que suceden en este
mecanismo de química órgano
con gran detalle nuestro objetivo es que
podamos entender cómo se usan los
núcleos y los hilos electro filos en un
mecanismo de química orgánica ok y ahora
veamos cómo es que estas flechas curvas
muestran el movimiento o flujo de
electrones veamos otro mecanismo de
química orgánica empecemos por
identificar al núcleo filo y al electro
filo entonces primero analicemos este
compuesto
sabemos que el oxígeno es más electro
negativo que el carbono por lo que este
oxígeno retira densidad electrónica de
este carbón y lo mismo ocurre con el
cloro porque el cloro también es más
electro negativo que el carbono así que
como este carbono es eficiente en
electrones tiene una carga parcial
positiva por lo tanto puede actuar como
un electro filo y del lado derecho
tenemos el ión acetato que lo podemos
obtener a partir del acetato de sodio y
este oxígeno tiene
la carga formal negativa así que el
oxígeno es el centro núcleo físico de
nuestra unión acetato y nuestra unión
acetato puede actuar como un núcleo filo
y como las cargas opuestas se atraen
entonces el oxígeno cargado
negativamente se siente atraído a este
carbono cargado positivamente podemos
decir que el núcleo filo ataca al
electro filo y he dibujado una flecha
curva para mostrar el movimiento de
estos dos electrones ahora no puedo
mostrar la formación de un enlace
directamente de este oxígeno a este
carbono hasta que tome estos electrones
py y los mueva al oxígeno de arriba
porque recuerden que el carbono nunca
debe de exceder el octeto de electrones
a su alrededor entonces déjenme dibujar
el movimiento de los electrones dibujaré
todo eso por aquí ahora tenemos el
oxígeno de arriba con tres pares de
electrones libres
lo que le da al oxígeno una carga formal
negativa entonces cuando mostramos el
movimiento de electrones decimos que dos
electrones de aquí se movieron hacia el
oxígeno y eso le da una carga formal
negativa y aún tenemos este cloro unido
a este carbono entonces vamos a dibujar
aquí tenemos el cloro que tiene tres
pares de electrones libres a su
alrededor y ahora hemos formado un nuevo
enlace se forma el enlace entre este
oxígeno y este carbono y vamos a
resaltar estos dos electrones de color
rojo entonces esos electrones de color
rojo forman un enlace entre el oxígeno y
el carbono y este oxígeno aún tiene un
par de electrones libres a su alrededor
ahí está y ahora vamos a dibujar lo que
nos falta de este lado aquí tenemos el
carbono después tenemos un par de
electrones libres en este oxígeno
y después tenemos un grupo metilo por
acá entonces el primer paso de este
mecanismo es el ataque núcleo físico
entonces escribimos paso 1 el núcleo
filo ataca al electro filo y resulta que
este es un mecanismo de 2 pasos porque
en el segundo paso perdemos al grupo
saliente entonces digamos que a un par
de electrones libres en este oxígeno se
mueven de regreso para reformar el
carbon hilo pero acuérdense que no
podemos sobrepasar el octeto de
electrones
eso significa que estos dos electrones
se van junto con el cloro se van con el
grupo saliente que en este caso es el
ión de cloro vamos a dibujar todos sus
electrones y todos estos electrones le
dan una carga negativa y entonces los
electrones de
vamos a ponerlos de color azul estos
electrones en azul se van junto con el
cloro para formar el año en cloruro que
es nuestro grupo saliente perdemos el
grupo saliente reformamos el doble
enlace y así obtenemos el producto final
y recuerden no se preocupen mucho por
los detalles del mecanismo nuestro
objetivo es solamente identificar el
núcleo filo y el electro filo conocer el
flujo de electrones y empezar a pensar
en los diferentes pasos del mecanismo el
ataque núcleo físico es muy común al
igual que la pérdida del grupo saliente
ahora veamos otro mecanismo de química
orgánica identifiquemos al núcleo filo y
al electro filo primero analicemos este
compuesto
sabemos que el oxígeno es más electro
negativo que este carbono
entonces el oxígeno retira un poco de
densidad electrónica del carbono con lo
que este carbono tiene una carga parcial
positiva entonces es
es el centro electro físico de este
compuesto ahora en el primer paso vamos
a agregar propio litio y sabemos que el
carbono es más electro negativo que el
litio entonces el carbono jala los
electrones para que estén más cerca de
él lo que le da este carbono una carga
parcial negativa o mejor dicho como la
diferencia de electro negatividad es muy
grande
podemos tomar los dos electrones que
tenemos en ese enlace y ponerlos en este
carbono entonces aquí tenemos 3 carbonos
vamos a dibujarlos y después tenemos 2
electrones en este carbono voy a
resaltar esos electrones de color rosa
estos 2 electrones se quedan con el
carbono que tenemos aquí y eso le da una
carga formal negativa tenemos un carbón
y como tenemos una unión cargado
negativamente este carbón es un
excelente núcleo filo
la porción electro física que ya
identificamos porque las cargas opuestas
se atraen la carga negativa es atraída a
la carga positiva así que en el primer
paso de nuestro mecanismo el núcleo fi
lo ataca al electro filo ahora aquí no
podemos simplemente mostrar un enlace
entre estos dos carbonos porque
tendríamos 10 electrones alrededor de
este carbono y eso sobrepasa el octeto
de electrones así que necesitamos mover
algunos electrones a otra parte por
ejemplo podemos tomar estos dos
electrones y moverlos al oxígeno
entonces en nuestro primer paso el
núcleo filo ataca al electro filo y así
formamos un enlace carbono carbono y
también tenemos un oxígeno aquí con tres
pares de electrones libres a su
alrededor lo que le da una carga formal
negativa ok y sigamos algunos de esos
electrones voy a resaltar los de color
azul
los electrones se van con el oxígeno y
le dan una carga formal negativa y ahora
vamos a formar un enlace entre los dos
carbonos y aquí es en donde algunos se
confunden un poco porque a veces puede
ser un poco difícil contar carbonos en
este caso necesitamos tener 3 carbonos
en nuestro núcleo filo y vamos a formar
un enlace y miren si observamos el
producto que tenemos aquí podemos ver
que nos da una pista de cómo dibujarlo
tenemos 3 carbonos 1 2 y 3 y los
electrones de color rosa forman este
enlace de aquí entonces vamos a dibujar
eso en nuestro intermediario aquí
tenemos nuestros 3 carbonos vamos a
resaltar los 1 2 y 3 y los electrones de
color rosa es decir estos electrones
forman un enlace entre este carbono y
este carbono los electrones de color
rosa forman un enlace entre estos dos
carbonos
este es nuestro intermediario entonces
el primer paso es el ataque núcleo
físico y para el segundo paso observen
que aquí tenemos una fuente de protones
miren iones hidrógeno dibujaré uno
rápidamente
aquí tenemos h tres o más tenemos una
carga formal positiva en el oxígeno ok
entonces el segundo paso de este
mecanismo es una reacción química ácido
base es una transferencia de protones
miren este oxígeno cargado negativamente
en nuestro intermediario actúa como una
base y toma un protón entonces digamos
que este par de electrones toma un
protón de laxe tres o más dejando estos
electrones en el oxígeno voy a resaltar
esos electrones de color rojo
estos electrones de color rojo toman
este protón y forman este enlace y aquí
está el protón que tomamos así que como
nuestro producto final hemos formado un
alcohol recuerden por ahora nuestro
objetivo solamente es identificar al
núcleo filo y al electro filo y bueno lo
último de lo que me gustaría hablarles
en este vídeo es algo a lo que yo llamo
los principios de swartz el doctor
swartz fue mi profesor de química
orgánica en la universidad un día me
dijo que la química orgánica solo
consiste en cinco cosas necesitamos
saber electrones de valencia necesitamos
entender la electro negatividad
necesitamos conocer las reacciones
químicas ha sido base
necesitamos saber sobre reacciones de
oxidación y reducción es decir redox y
necesitamos entender que son los núcleos
y los hilos electro filos entonces si
regresamos al mecanismo anterior veamos
como es que este mecanismo contiene esos
cinco principios
pero hablemos de los electrones de
valencia en nuestro mecanismo estamos
mostrando las flechas curvas como esta o
esta para mostrar el movimiento de los
electrones de valencia y usamos mucho la
electro negatividad porque así fue como
supimos cuál era el núcleo filo y el
electro filo ahora el tercer principio
del profesor swartz es sobre las
reacciones ha sido base y eso es lo que
ocurre en el segundo paso de este
mecanismo verdad entonces el segundo
paso del mecanismo es una reacción
química ácido base se encontrarán con
muchas reacciones ha sido base en los
mecanismos de química el cuarto
principio son las reacciones redux y en
realidad esta es una reacción redox
porque si asignamos los estados de
oxidación verán que nuestro compuesto
inicial es reducido la acetona es
reducida a un alcohol
e identificar al núcleo filo y al
electro filo fue el primer paso de
nuestro mecanismo y es en lo que más nos
hemos enfocado así que bueno no
necesariamente tenemos que tener todas
esas cinco cosas en un solo mecanismo
pero como este tenía todas les quise
hablar de los principios del profesor
swartz porque si comprenden muy bien los
cinco conceptos los mecanismos serán
mucho más fáciles para ustedes